bonjour connaissez vous le site wiki
nous essayons d'aider chaque personne
sur la planète apprendre comment tout
faire rejoignez-nous c'est un site
regroupant des articles pour ta propre
affaire à vivre finalement comment
réussir un examen comment père en fille
à l'école comment être heureux tous les
jours et chaque article est accompagné
d'une petite illustration semble
représenter comme par exemple cette
image représente l'article comment jouer
à action vérité est ce qu'avec seulement
l'image vous auriez pu trouver le nom de
l'article
la réponse est peut-être c'est parti on
concède du groupe direct on a donc à
chaque fois quatre propositions de
titres d'articles il faut trouver là
qu'elle est bonne comment trouver un
mari quand les femmes sont plus
nombreuses que les hommes dans ton pays
comment faire une lapdance pour tous
copains anbari comment aider les gens
paranoïaque ou comment dire à une fille
que tu l'aies mme bah c'est le dernier
ou alors le premier en mode ya trop de
femmes du coup une personne pourra
toucher les seins à moi j'ai la dernière
y est ok suivant c'est un mec qui pense
à un mec qui a peut-être plusieurs
émotions
est ce qu'on croise des descriptions
comment danser en boîte de nuit comment
échanger avec une personne sarcastique
comment être un adolescent studieux au
nom de ma grille et comment réagir aux
fondamentalistes je dirai comment gérer
une personne sarcastique 2,02 pour moi
sont beaux mais vous allez rester à 0 si
vous pouvez pas jouer au hockey play
against facile aux [ __ ] juste une
horloge avec plein d'aiguilhe comment
gérer avec des parents très chrétien
commun se sentir bien dans sa peau comme
en faire des cauchemars ou comment
transformer une fille une horloge avec
genre en mode à quelle heure est il
je suis perdu ah je suis pas bien dans
ma peau ag ufo comment faire des
cauchemars il ya le lien vers le vrai
article mais qui suit un tuto pour faire
des cauchemars alors il faut dormir le
visage vers l'oreiller il faut essayer
de manger certains trucs avant de dormir
moi je peux dire quelque chose puis mon
pote c'est plutôt toi et que tu vas
passer la nuit et fais-toi peur avant
d'aller dormir prendre la vitamine b6 ok
y'a une bouche fermée c'est validé une
bouche ouverte c'est pas validé comment
faire du alto saxophone ces sages simek
voit la fin des gars je sais pas d'où je
sors cette reconnaissance mon gars je
crois que c'est un cauchemar que j'ai
provoqué cette nuit excellent ce petit
running gag chier plus j'ai eu ça mais
il faut pas faire ça faut faire preuve
de musique à mi temps je sais ça soit ok
c'est une fille avec un appareil photo
une longue vue je sais pas comment
acheter des armes à feu en californie
comment choisir une université
rigoureuse pour ta première année
comment être moins collant comment
reconnaître les signes d'intoxication je
pensais être moins collant en voiture la
photo elle observe de loin comme simple
il est seul à faire ça au collège
jacinthe fioles de laboratoire que c'est
un truc au rapport comment faire en
sorte qu'un mec que tu as sous les
thèmes la prochaine fois que tu le vois
comment être taquin comment savoir quand
tu auras tes premières règles ou comment
s'amuser sans tes amis voilà c'est
peut-être un peu sale mais c'est pas le
délire avec les cuillères à soupe de
sang genre rapport aux règles sur une
semaine ça fait peut-être 5 cuillères à
soupe de sange
ou alors elle prépare une potion pour
que le mec qui ne l'est plus l'aiment à
nouveau bible là comment savoir quand tu
auras tes premières est un habitué à
aller du challenge une femme qui regarde
d'un air étonné sa collègue qui pense à
un chat avec une moustache
comment savoir si tout comportement du
respect comment être intéressante
comment aimer comment être un bon mari
comment est intéressante
walt est bien celle à deux aventuriers
qui cherche quelqu'un priori comment
survivent dans les bois concerne ta
copine me faire l'amour
comment acheter d'électronique usagers
comment refuser un bisou algérie qui
sont dans les bois et qu'ils appelaient
à l'autre puisqu'ils sont dans la merde
donc comment survivent dans les bois je
suis un génie oh [ __ ] avec nous
embrouille notre coeur bat super vite
comment réagir si quelqu'un te traite de
marche comment voir à travers les gens
comment se faire percer les tétons
cesana bonne et ça ça c'est un abonné
qui apprécient le tt comment garder son
calme mais aurait pas fait un article
aussi ciblé que faire si quelqu'un dit
que tu es moche l'instant ces derniers
commencent calme et beau un mec qui
allume sa clope à l'envers avec une
allumette comment reconnaître les signes
d'intoxication comment gagner un combat
au point d'en écrire un sketch ou
comment être unique voie des airs
d'intoxication c'est sûr bah oui on
était facile où naissent au plus tard il
fit qui se fait éclaboussé comment
comprendre légaux des hommes
ça nous concerne beaucoup comment faire
une blague ou comment faire preuve de
respect gérer c'est la blague
ouais bah oui oh [ __ ] un couple qui
regarde un match au bowling on n'a
jamais vu ces personnes au regard du
bowling à la télé on couple comment être
joli comment montrer à votre mari vous
voulez mais comment capturer la joie de
vivre
ou comment faire face à la mort d'un ami
je dirais soit comment montrer son amour
envers son mari jean regarder sa passion
à la télé alors que tu aimes pas
forcément ça en l'occurrence le bowling
soit la junte juive soit ça peut tous
être là en fait allez on va dire ce que
je vous ai dit oui au une fille qui sait
ce qu s'exclame comment être sans
émotion comment faire des crasses à ton
copain comment ne pas être nerveux ou
comment ference a ou comment rendre
quelqu'un qui a rencontré sur msn
amoureux de toi moi c'est soit ne pas
ressentir l'émotion soin de pet nerveux
même panne avant la butte à l'heure donc
gérer que c'est ça son émotion
comment agir seulement avec votre copain
réagir un truc banal avec une réaction
exagérée tu as mangé deux bananes à toi
tout seul tu es s'attend pas fait tomber
une ouais mais les gars
c'est le bel professionnel l'a amputé un
magnifique c'est là comment perdre son
visage comment s'amuser sur ses amis
comment savoir si ton copain et
irrespectueux envers toi comment est
attirante en rendez vous comment refuser
un bisou juste une meuf qui a refusé
vision un modèle prend son village à
l'envoyeur loin du visage de l'autre je
pense c'est le bisou c'est comment
s'amuser sans ses amis ça représente
quoi cette [ __ ] d illustration l ai
même pas dedans
elle y est même par la douille comment
utiliser le français dans une
conversation à propos des mammifères à
laisser ça aux et voilà moi j'ai pas le
temps mort par contre mais j'aimerais
bien savoir où ils ont quel est-il
en fait c'est un tuto pour apprendre le
nombre d'animaux en français et l'image
à contrôler et à l'instruction volés
chaque mois au dos de la carte
correspondante c'est passionnant mais
parfois aussi couramment je m'en bats
les couilles
ok quelqu'un qui se baissent comment
survivre à un hiver froid comment savoir
quand tu vas voir les premières règles
comment rendre un ami amoureux de toi
comment faire une danse mboa ce peut
être la danse non c'est débile je pense
et survivre à un hiver froid faire un
vieux truc un vieux move qui fait que tu
as moins froid chez pas quoi eh ben
c'est de la merde cette théorie comment
faire une danse et mot [ __ ] en garant
des mecs qui disent ce tutorat pour de
vrai d'accord un mec qui fait non c'est
comment refuser poliment un tract dans
la rue tu paries comment péter
silencieusement bon dans les très longs
comment être le genre de geek que les
filles adorent comment parler avec
autorité
comment arrêter de fixer le décolleté
les filles ont réussi la dernière
affaire toutes les options ensemble sur
l'image il dit c'est pas moi qui ai pété
soit sur l'image c'est le cliché du geek
un peu bg qui fait d'eux non désolé je
suis pas intéressé fille est peu
probable quand même par les autorités
n'en serait rien passé je me bats
théorie a été fixée les décolletés je
pense que c'est
ah non c'était comment arrêter de
regarder le décolleté défi tient pas
comment faire dis-nous étape 1 regarder
ailleurs
merci très bon si tu commences personnes
cette vidéo n'était pas là mais ça vous
a plu je n'avais pas cette étape une
espace était bien sympa ce petit jeu on
va pas se mentir il aura peut-être une
deuxième vidéo tu vois la revanche on
veut avoir le 70% de bonnes réponses qui
correspond à un petit 14 sur 20 à 10% 9
ans a fait 2 2 x 7 14 voix la bcao
regardé comme d'habitude j'espère que
vous me portez bien que tout se passe
bien dans votre ville les bonnes notes
sont là que les gays mort enquête se
passe bien peu importe le jeu auquel
vous jouez que vous regardez pas trop
décolletée défi parce que vous avez
suivi ce tuto uni quoi je voulais être
une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien tu as tout le monde